welcome everybody on the path of the
ethics politics and economics major
we're so pleased to have all of you here
for the littlest lecture and before I
introduce our distinguished speaker and
want to tell you a little bit about what
this literate lectureships is Robert H
litoris was a well trained
began his training and the scholar is a
lawyer he was at Columbia Law School and
he had kind of change of heart and
decided that what he was really
interested in was ethics and the
importance of ethics in social policy so
in came to the Yale Divinity School
and tragically while he was at the
animation school he was diagnosed with
cancer and upon hearing this he 7/5 a
truck and in fact devoted the remaining
efforts to building this trust that
would then become the endowment for the
literate lectureship on ethics and
social policy so we're so pleased to
have his legacy so meaningfully borne
out by this lectureship that brings to
life real-life concerns about ethics in
the world today we're also honored to
have with us the center Laurie little
bit who is an established international
artist and who comes all the way to us
from Mexico
[Applause]
so I'm also delighted of course to
introduce to you our speaker this year's
little wits lecturer Ben Weisner
graduate of Harvard College and the NYU
School of Law he now directs the ACL
u--'s speech privacy and technology
project so these are impressive
credentials but a lot of you of course
are here because since July 2013 Ben
Widener has been the lead lawyer for
Edwin and Edwin Edwards thank you Edward
Snowden and he's been leading this
project of thinking about what it means
to have free speech and national
security so tightly intertwined in
American politics so there's no one
better to help us think about the
ethical legal and political complexities
of cyber security but he has one other
claim to fame which is that he is the
son of Steve and Rachel Widener who are
also here with us today and Steve Weiser
is the William O Douglas clinical
professor emeritus of law the Yale Law
School and Rachel Weiser among other
things was a Dean of which College
Pearson college and both of them have
led exemplary careers of helping the
vulnerable and being upright and just
the best kind of citizen of the world so
I have to think that maybe they were
some of the inspiration for your very
public service oriented career so Ben
Weisner speaking to us today about the
peculiar politics of national security
thanks for that introduction Fran this
is the wrong day for me to be speaking
without a microphone because I picked up
a bug that travels around offices so if
you can't hear me in the back please
wave and I'll try to project a little
bit more it's an honor to be included
among the distinguished people who have
given this lecture before me of course I
did a little bit of research to see who
they were and I'm really grateful to be
here you're looking at a photograph of
the very first Air Force one this was
Harry Truman's presidential plane and it
was on this plane in 1947 that Truman
signed the National Security Act one of
the founding documents of the security
state now as it happens this particular
plane was nicknamed the sacred cow which
could hardly be more appropriate the
comment definition of sacred cow is
something that has been accepted or
respected for a long time and that
people are afraid or unwilling to
question it seems to me quite an apt
description of what we've come to call
national security my remarks today will
be something of a provocation I began my
career as an ACLU lawyer just five weeks
before the 9/11 attacks and I've spent
the decade and a half since then trying
to bring constitutional principles into
a space increasingly defined by
constitutional exception in my own very
particular experience the word national
security has looked a lot like a bubble
in at least two senses of that word it's
been isolated from opposing world views
or even opposing facts and it has
experienced a rapid growth that is
wildly out of proportion from its
underlying reason for being so before I
go further down this line let me clarify
what I don't mean by national security
I'm not referring to national defense
which we might define as a nation's use
of military power and intelligence
assets to maintain its survival and I'm
not referring to public safety which we
might define as the use of police powers
to protect the public from crime or
other non existential or non-territorial
dangers I'm referring to something more
nebulous and elusive a kind of civic
religion that has arisen in the decades
since Truman signed the National
Security Act and that hasn't rained
itself as the nation's paramount and
defining interest this religion has its
own priesthood in the high offices of
the defense and intelligence communities
its clergy members in the halls of the
Capitol thank you edits deacons and
altar boys spread around think tanks and
academies and the theology of national
security is predicated on a series of
core tenets or articles of faith if you
will that I'll argue are highly
questionable
and yet rarely questioned these baseline
assumptions are so commonly accepted
that we become desensitized to how truly
extreme and anti-democratic
they are my hope today is to begin to
remiss defy them so I will explore some
of those tenets of the national security
priesthood and why I think they're so
consequential by allowing this category
error to metastasize without clear
boundaries we diminish our democracy by
fundamentally weakening critical
oversight mechanisms and in a time of
genuine constitutional crisis such as
the one that we may be experiencing now
they leave us with fewer tools of
resistance at precisely the moment when
those tools are most needed so what are
these core tenets of the National
Security priesthood the first and most
important is this we live in uniquely
dangerous times sometimes it's put
another way we face an unprecedented
Brett and despite words like unique and
unprecedented this tenet appears to be
evergreen it's exemplified by Senator
Lindsey Graham's remarkable but also
typical statement in May of 2015 we have
never seen more threats against our
nation and its citizens than we do today
so let's paraphrase the framers of the
Constitution may have had certain ideas
about the need to restrain government
but they never faced a threat like
al-qaeda or Isis or cyber attacks by
state or non-state actors we saw the
same kind of thinking in Alberto
Gonzalez's reprehensible dismissal of
the Geneva Conventions as quaint and
obsolete these statements to be
charitable are absurd relative to
population the casualty figures for the
Revolutionary War were staggering
compared to more recent conflicts indeed
that war represents the very definition
of an existential national struggle and
the authors of the 1949 Geneva
Conventions had just emerged from total
war in which 50 million people most of
them civilians had been killed to call
those people naive is the height of
narcissism
so let's engage in a thought exercise
what would the framers of the
Constitution or the drafters of the
Geneva Conventions have made of a
society in which at most one in four
million people was likely to die in a
terrorist attack but the government
nonetheless routinely frightened the
public with color-coded terror alerts
somehow I don't think they would have
been impressed now a corollary of this
tenet is that today's terrorists are
uniquely lethal supervillains normal
prisons can't hold them and of course
they can never be released and so we
heard the nation's top uniformed
military officer warn us in 2002
at Guantanamo housed the worst of the
worst in his words the sort of people
who would chew through a hydraulics
cable to bring down a c-17 transport
plane in New York City we saw the deeply
cynical protests by local elected
officials who opposed holding the trial
of the alleged 9/11 perpetrators in
federal court in Manhattan on safety
grounds the result of that effort is
that nearly 16 years after the 9/11
attacks the trial of the alleged
perpetrators has not even begun
something that should be ashamed to
everybody in this room now it is
important to qualify that this view of
terrorists as super villains who will
kill us all is not shared by everybody
in the Security States and you hear very
different things in private
conversations in 2007 or 2008 I was
invited to a dinner with a very senior
military official one who would go on to
serve on the Joint Chiefs of Staff and I
said to him at that dinner if you closed
Guantanamo today and offered each
detainee a weapon of his choice and
dropped him off on the battlefield of
his choice
they would collectively do less harm to
this country than you're doing by
keeping Guantanamo open his response a
high-five but the fact that this person
would never acknowledge that view in
public is a consequence of the perverse
really upside down politics of national
security our prevailing political
discourse rewards leaders who inflate
the terrorist threat and marginalizes
those who accurately contextualize it so
those who proclaim that today's
terrorists represent an unprecedented
threat to our way of life that our
existing laws courts and institutions
even our prisons are inadequate in the
face of this threat that we have no
choice but to dispense with core
principles including even the
prohibition against torturing prisoners
to defeat this ruthless enemy that
ensured 9/11 changed
reasoning are extolled as hard-nosed
realists warriors who are willing to
take the gloves off by contrast those
who defend the vitality and viability of
our constitutional system who insists
that our existing institutions are equal
to the challenges posed by transnational
terrorism who demand that we abide by
core principles including fair trials
for and humane treatment of prisoners
even if that means that terrorism
suspects have to be released and
political leaders have to be prosecuted
who ensure do not believe that the
threat of terrorism changed everything
are dismissed as weak and naive
afflicted by a pre 9/11 mindset now I
think this insistence on the language of
war says less about the nature of our
adversary and the nature of our conflict
and much more about the identity needs
of our own would-be warriors here we see
that former defense secretary Donald
Rumsfeld has named his solitaire app
play Churchill now leave aside for a
moment that Rumsfeld's real-world
attempt to play Churchill ended rather
badly and that the world is still
suffering the consequences and look
who's playing Churchill now now is it
possible that Lindsey Graham is right
and I'm wrong and that terrorism is in
fact the existential threat that he
would have us believe it is and that but
for the wars and aggressive
counterterrorism policies that people
like me have criticized we would have
seen dozens of catastrophic terrorist
attacks in these last 15 years sure it's
possible as a noted solitaire app
developer once said absence of evidence
is not evidence of absence
this line of argument recalls the old
joke there's a man standing in the
middle of Times Square with a sign that
says Tigers keep out and a passerby asks
him what's with the sign there's no
Tigers in New York City and the man nods
knowingly it's working this is our
difficulty we cannot say what the world
would look like if we didn't throw
hundreds of billions of dollars at this
problem but if the lack of attacks is
evidence that our strategy is working
and more attacks are evidence that we
need even more counterterrorism
resources than we seem to have been
trapped in a one-way ratchet I would add
that if our intelligence community were
routinely thwarting deadly attacks it
would be in their nature to boast about
it
here you see former Attorney General
John Ashcroft in Moscow of June in June
of 2002 where he interrupted his visit
to announce in a creepy video to the
world that the u.s. had captured one
Jose Padilla who was allegedly involved
in a plot to detonate dirty bombs in
major American cities now even at that
time the evidence for that assertion
was paper-thin we now know that it was
much more fantasy than threat and recall
that government officials have made
similarly breathless announcements about
the thwarting of comically inept
terrorist plots many of them of course
initiated by FBI informants one of my
favorites was the so-called Cedars Tower
plot a nefarious attempt to knock down
the iconic tower so that it would fall
into Lake Michigan and create a tsunami
Vice President Dick Cheney described
that one as a very real threat the truth
is as the security expert Bruce Schneier
has said there aren't a lot of
terrorists out there America is full of
big guns and soft targets if it were
also full of sleeper cells we would know
it by now and this leads to an
uncomfortable question how have the
leaders and defenders of the security
state
persuaded the citizens of the safest and
most secure society in human history
that the Huns are perennial e at our
doorstep I'm afraid I don't have the
answer to that question but can there be
any doubt that the ceaseless drumbeat of
security state rhetoric about the
seriousness of the terror threat created
fertile ground for a presidential
candidate to propose policies like a
Muslim ban and a border wall and to
issue executive orders targeting the
citizens of countries responsible for
zero American deaths and terrorist
attacks moving on to the next tenet of
the national security priesthood
security is our paramount national
interest now this view is widely held
and often stated even the Supreme Court
of the United States which should know
better has written that it is obvious
and in arguable that the security of the
nation is its preeminent interest is
that so
it's certainly not clear that the
framers of the Constitution would agree
here's the preamble to the Constitution
as my friend the journalist Bart Gellman
has observed the preamble identifies not
one but the six basic purposes that we
the people intend our government to
advance fourth among them is to provide
for the common defense Union justice and
tranquility precede that goal welfare
and liberty follow as Bart says there's
a tone of catholicity here we the people
care a lot about the common defense but
defense has peers in our pantheon it is
now entirely common to refer to the
President as commander-in-chief of the
nation not of the Armed Forces a
formulation that miss perceives the
president's constitutional role even as
it makes all of us soldiers as we sit at
our computers tweeting and deleting
emails now a corollary of this tenet if
it makes us safer it being a policy we
should do it
if it makes it safer we should do it all
too often in the post 9/11 conversations
about terrorism it has seemed that the
only question we should be asking is
whether a proposed government action
keeps us safe we know from many other
non national security context that this
framing is incomplete at best we know
and we reject all manner of policies and
regulations that would demonstrably make
us safer we know for example that we
could reduce deaths from automobile
accidents quite dramatically if we use
sophisticated surveillance technologies
to strictly enforce speed limits we
could require that every new car be
fitted with a breathalyzer device that
links to the ignition so that no car
could be started by someone under the
influence of alcohol
we could have sobriety checkpoints every
few miles some of you may be nodding I
see you mom
I'm thinking that these are good ideas
great you can use the political process
to advocate for policies like these if
and when they're proposed others of you
will say that the increases in Road
Safety are not worth the cost and
liberty but being issued automatic
speeding violations by computers or of
having TSA level security on all of our
roads and highways the real question is
how much safer do we want to be and how
much are we willing to pay in rights and
dollars for that increase in safety
we're already pretty safe from
terrorists and we should be wary of
political rhetoric that leaves little
room for other core constitutional
values let's keep in mind that the
authors of the Constitution and Bill of
Rights would have been perplexed by a
political discourse that subordinated
hard-won rights to talismanic
invitations of national security indeed
those documents were written to make the
government law enforcement and security
functions more difficult not easier just
look at the Bill of Rights the Fourth
Amendment the
government can't search or seize without
a warrant supported by probable cause of
wrongdoing the Fifth Amendment the
government can't force us to be
witnesses against ourselves the
prosecutors don't get two bites of the
Apple government can't take away our
freedom or our property without due
process the sixth amendment we all get a
lawyer a public trial by jury we can
confront the evidence against us the
eighth amendment they can't beat
evidence out of us and the only way to
read those words written 200 years ago
is to see that their authors were more
worried about a government with too much
power than about the bad guys who would
inevitably get away now a second
corollary of this tenet allows the high
priests of the security state to
position themselves as the real
defenders of civil liberties and human
rights and I often hear arguments like
this one from government officials if
you think these policies are bad just
wait until there's another terrorist
attack the public is going to demand
much worse the implied takeaway is that
we should gratefully allow the erosion
of rights in order to prevent the
erosion of still more rights this
formulation is an unhelpful straw man
it's a straw man because nobody is
arguing that our police military and
spies should unilaterally disarm
virtually all of us support targeted
counterterrorism measures that are
proportional to the threat and it's
unhelpful because it tells us nothing
about where difficult lines should be
drawn the third tenet we should defer to
the expertise of national security
officials now this anodyne sounding
principle has been at the heart of the
security states successful efforts to
neuter a constitutional oversight by the
courts in Congress and I think of all
the tenets of the national security
state this one might have seemed the
most alien to the Constitution's framers
the structure of our constitutional
system is predicated on mistrust of
aggregated Authority the very purpose of
divided government and of constitutional
protection for a free press was the
framers belief that leaders would use
their power for improper
purposes not because they were evil but
because they were human with the leaders
of the security state called deference
to their own expertise the framers would
have recognized as a structural conflict
of interest so for example when we at
the ACLU sued CIA officials for their
mistaken kidnapping and brutal treatment
of our client Khalid el-masri it was the
CIA itself that invoked the
state-secrets privilege and successfully
sought dismissal of the suit on grounds
that litigation of our claims against
them would harm national security let me
put this another way a torture victims
lawsuit was dismissed in deference to
the expertise of an affidavit submitted
by the perpetrators themselves secrecy
doctrines like that one are the method
most often used to enforce this
principle of deference executive branch
officials are literally indoctrinated
and this is their term not mine
into the world of security clearance
which I prefer to call the deep state
honor taught and the security clearance
regime allows government officials to
put forward the corollary of the
deference rule if you only knew what we
knew if you only saw what we saw you
would understand why we have to do what
we do when you hear that
be sure to keep in mind that the most
grievous and damaging decisions
affecting the national security have
always been made by officials with
access to the most closely guarded
secrets I'm here I want to tell you
about a conversation I had with now
former Israeli Supreme Court justice
Taran Barak who teaches here at the law
school every fall when I was litigated
these state secrets cases against the
CIA and others I asked him what would
you do if you got a declaration and
affidavit from the head of the CIA
saying that allowing this case to go
forward would harm national security
would you do what these American judges
have done and dismissed it he said I'll
tell you what I did do there was
litigation about where a security wall
should be
separating Israel from the occupied
territories and the army thought it
should go here and the human rights
groups that were challenging it thought
it should go here and I said to the army
when they said we're the experts in
national security I said yes you are you
are the experts in security and I am the
expert in proportionality I am the one
who is best able to consider the other
competing values at stake and so the
logos here now that approach has allowed
the Israeli High Court to issue
important presidential decisions about
torture targeted killing and other
highly sensitive security issues even as
their US counterparts have dismissed all
of those cases in deference to
government claims of secrecy fourth I'm
going to take a short dick national
security officials who break the law do
so in good faith advocates who seek to
hold them legally kept legally
accountable do so in bad faith this
tenet holds that our national security
officials are uniformly honorable public
servants working under extreme pressure
while human rights advocates who
second-guess their decisions are
practicing law fair a kind of asymmetric
warfare waged from the safety of our
Fifth Column the term law fair itself
has generally been defined as the
strategy of using or misusing law as a
substitute for traditional military
means to achieve an operational
objective now remarkably this is how the
high priests of the deep state and their
apologists tend to view any efforts to
hold them accountable for grave
violations of the Constitution the
Brookings Institution's Benjamin witness
who I don't need to single out but will
editor-in-chief of the law fair blog the
law fair blog if you're not familiar
with it operates as a kind of online
Clubhouse for the national security set
has defended the notorious Department of
Justice torture memos which purported to
authorize
interrogation techniques that the US had
long considered criminal as the good
faith work of lawyers who were in his
words addressing very hard questions
under extraordinarily hard circumstances
but listened to how he describes a human
rights organization that criticized the
Obama administration for its political
decision to look forward rather than
backward and to decline even to
investigate the architects of the Bush
administration's torture conspiracy with
us again what human rights first calls
accountability for torture is in my book
the criminalization of policy
differences nothing more or less nothing
more or less in four words he briefly
dismisses a deeply established body of
domestic and international law including
treaties to which our country is
signatory and accuses human rights
defenders of pursuing a partisan
political vendetta which is of course
exactly backwards
it was the torturers and their
apologists who were politicizing the law
not human rights advocates who were
criminalizing politics but this sense of
outraged dignity at the notion that
honorable public servants who were
protecting the nation could have their
actions second-guessed by naive
idealists is a common trope of national
security
discourse the result is that there is
virtual impunity for any senior security
state official who insists that his
alleged misconduct was carried out under
the banner of national security and so
for example every single lawsuit brought
by a victim of the Bush administration's
torture regime has been dismissed
without any adjudication of either the
law or the facts this of course means
that the perpetrators have escaped
accountability and the victims have been
deprived of any remedy but equally
important our system of justice has been
deprived of a definitive adjudication of
the lawfulness of the alleged conduct so
should we be surprised when a new
president feel
was free to relitigate this question can
we even call it relitigated when we were
never allowed to litigate it in the
first place so to sum up briefly the
ideology of national security has taught
us that the world is always a very scary
place and that Islamic terror is on par
with earlier existential threats to our
nation that security should be our
primary national concern the courts and
Congress should generally defer to the
expertise of executive branch officials
on national security questions and that
executive officials should be exempt
from legal accountability because their
activities even their abuses are always
carried out in service of the nation now
it's more than a little bit ironic to me
that the national security actors and
cheerleaders who brought us this
ideology many of whom have now emerged
as critics of President Donald Trump
seems to have very little sense that
they've spent the last several decades
helping to lay the groundwork for a
fear-based
presidency and advocating the weakening
of constitutional constraints that were
put in place precisely to protect us
from a malignant actor like Trump so as
discordant as it may be I'm going to try
to end on a note of optimism after all
of that if only so that I can show this
slide
if nothing else the events of the last
weeks and months have made clear that
national security politics are a game
with serious consequences what would it
look like to have a different kind of
national security politics how might we
envision a politics based more on
courage than on fear more on resilience
than on reaction and we have to ask is
fear of terrorism as deep-seated as our
leaders seem to believe it is or is it a
language that we've all grown accustomed
to
I think there's reason to believe that
the public might be grateful for a
different kind of conversation about
security and terrorism I think we saw
some of this sentiment in the tens of
thousands of Americans who spontaneously
flocked to airports to protest the Trump
administration's ban and refugees and
visitors from predominantly Muslim
countries I'm convinced that those
demonstrations played a critical role in
the decisions of the judges to enjoin
the enforcement of Trump's orders we
like to think of our courts as insulated
somehow from the political tides but I
think the opposite is true a frightened
public will contribute to judicial
decisions upholding abusive security
policies and a courageous public will
embolden judges to stand up for human
rights and civil rights a short anecdote
some years ago when those color-coded
terror alerts were still the norm I was
watching CNN during one of those
Department of Homeland Security
announcements setting the threat level
at orange I believe after a few minutes
of somber sounding terrorism experts
expounding on the latest terrorist
chatter CNN split the screen to show
other breaking news a dog floating on a
piece of ice was being rescued by the
Coast Guard and if after a few more
minutes
the terror alert disappeared and the
full screen was given over to the dog
ice rescue now after the last few months
we probably all feel a little bit like
the dog on the ice but the point that
I'm trying to make is that this episode
revealed how much our security discourse
has operated as a kind of theater I have
the sense that the American people are
ready for something more substantial I
believe the public would respond to a
politics that places courage back at the
center of citizenship let's remind our
leaders because they've failed to remind
us that in our national anthem land of
the free and home of the brave appear in
the same Clause and let's tell them that
the only thing that truly frightens us
is that our leaders might burn down the
village in order to save it that is that
in the name of defending the nation
they'll make it a place not worth
defending so thank you so much for
listening and I would be glad to answer
questions and have a conversation
[Applause]
let's leave resilience on the screen
then why don't you field the question
yeah I'd be happy to
so who wants to be first would you
comment on the security issue regarding
our political figures and the president
where that fits and the things with you
talking can you say a little more about
what you mean what security it seems to
me there's more and more security it's
called for them for around them
correction yes around them in the
Attorney General and the EPA person
everybody's getting security is just
like you know your folks
yeah I haven't thought a lot about this
one I mean certainly we've had how many
presidential assassinations have we had
in this country at least two is it more
than two Dennis three and then we'd have
candidates who were cuz I it's it's not
exactly where I would plant my flag as a
critique in saying that there's too much
of a bubble around the President himself
but we have seen in this administration
is that even the Secretary of Education
and the you know EPA Administrator have
demanded you know much much more
security than others have but but again
I don't know whether that's a reflection
of increased threats because of
increased political polarization you
know there is something regrettable you
know about a world where there's such a
gap between a security bubble that they
move in and the rest of us but I'm more
concerned about the conversational
bubble that people in government don't
think that anybody who lacks a security
clearance could have anything important
to say about policy I'm more worried
about them being trapped in that bubble
than I am about too much Secret Service
Denny
a lot of rhetoric about you should trust
us is a couple with assertions that we
have actually aborted several down
serious attempts to do bad things
now do you know of any any data at all
about whether about just anything yeah
what what so so again the the the
assertion that but for such and such
counterterrorism policies there would
have been this number of attacks is one
that can't be disproven it's it's like
all like any conspiracy theory there's
it set up so that there's no fact that
could be brought in that would disprove
it but there are some facts that are
useful so one that I'm familiar with the
first program that was revealed in the
Snowden revelations was a program in
which the NSA on a daily basis was
collecting the metadata of all phone
calls from all the major phone companies
and turning them over storing them for
five years right and so when this
program was revealed the NSA came
forward and said that the program had
been critical to stopping 54 terrorist
plots which seemed like a alarming
number under scrutiny including from
members of Congress who had security
clearance and who had been briefed on
this that number kept going down until
it was won The New Yorker wrote a whole
article about that one and that one was
a Somali American cabdriver who had sent
$8,000 back to Mogadishu to someone who
might have been connected to the Shabaab
right so what you saw there was the
progression from national security
officials coming out to the podium and
saying they stopped 54 terrorist attacks
to the quiet story in a more fringe
publication that a few people read that
said actually it was only one and even
that one was [ __ ] so again you know
we know that as I said before
in their nature to boast about their
successes it's the vice president is
saying that the Sears Tower plot is a
very real threat that they you know that
they managed to wrap up then they don't
have a lot of things that they can brag
about again it's you know from the
outside looking in it's impossible for
me to say with evidence that their
claims are lives but I believe that with
all my heart yes national security being
at an unprecedented level of danger now
but also talk about talking about civil
liberties how where it seems like the
rhetoric around it is that our liberties
are also at an unprecedented level of
danger and that seems to be something
like I mean before whether now it's
unprecedented before you know during the
McCarthy era what was going on and
before with FDR trying to pass the cords
and Lincoln in suspending habeas corpus
is it just our civil liberties just
perpetually in you know this kind of
crisis of you know being taken away was
there a time when they were not yeah
it's a really good question I um you
know the way that a civil libertarian
would answer that is that none of this
isn't inheritance all of this is
contested
none of these victories are things that
we can take for granted the terrain is
going to have to be fought over
constantly but that doesn't mean that
there aren't enormous spikes
traditionally those have happened in
wartime and there's a very interesting
article written by the late Justice
Brennan about civil liberties in wartime
that he delivered as a lecture at Hebrew
University you know where he said
basically we have this tradition in this
country of suspending habeas corpus
during the Civil War in turning the
japanese-americans during World War two
Cold War you know McCarthyism but that
we come to our senses so there's a sort
of elasticity we realized that we went
too far and we came back I think the
reason why people like me have been so
concerned about the post 9/11
environment is not because what happens
is worse than the Japanese internment of
course it isn't but because in those
earlier Wars looking back at them the
people who were in the middle of them
didn't know when they were going to end
but they more or less knew how they were
going to end right World War two was
going to end with someone surrendering
somewhere but what happens when you
define a war the way that we define war
now what will the end look like you know
so have we are we in training a
permanent state of exception and are we
out of that cyclical model where things
got worse and they got better so that's
the real concern is and that the other
part of it is that that you know with
habeas corpus with the internment I mean
usually there came a time when the legal
system stepped in after the fact and too
late to vindicate the core rights at
issue so you know the Supreme Court said
in 1866 that Lincoln was wrong to
suspend habeas corpus Thanks but but
maybe that was the right way of dealing
with it you know don't try to tie the
president hands down in the next
potential civil war but vindicate the
principle afterwards the problem is we
haven't seen the principles vindicated
here so that because of these
justiciability doctrines like secrecy
and standing and so and so we haven't
had courts come in and say you know what
what you did to these prisoners in cages
by beating them some of them to death
was illegal there's no decision holding
that anything that the Bush
administration did to detainees was
illegal every one of those cases was
thrown out so that's another concern
about it but but I do take your point
that there can be outrage fatigue and
and that we should watch our rhetoric
yes domestic security so I'm thinking
sort of the militarization and lack of a
determinate intelligence ization
of policing and how we can to defend
local defensible liberties on the local
level and it seems like it's becoming so
yeah enmeshed of the national security
well what you see is the migration of
both security technology and security
policy from you know military
intelligence
in war zones back into local communities
so obviously the images of you know
armored police vehicles going through
cities are the you know the the most
dramatic and the ones that show that the
most or or SWAT teams on a marijuana
raid with you know sixteen armed
officers with with machine guns shooting
people's dogs as they go in right but it
happens a lot with surveillance
technologies to things that are
developed for use in war zones finding
their way back home
you could understand why in a war zone
you might want to have a drone flying
overhead 24 hours with a sophisticated
camera so that even if you can't stop
the ie D from blowing up your troop
carrier you can hit rewind on the tape
see what village the person came from
follow the person back but do we really
want to use that same technology to
solve every liquor store robbery and so
a lot of these request technologies get
pushed out to terrorism task forces or
drug task forces in the in the
communities without really any local
input so a lot of the stuff goes through
federal government grants that
circumvent local political processes so
one of the things that we've been doing
is trying to push City Council's you
know the ultimate local government to
pass ordinances saying that these cities
will not accept even free you know
military or surveillance technology from
the federal government without some kind
of local input some kind of debate about
what they're going to be used for in
some vote on whether they're going to
accept it and we've gotten a couple
dozen cities to take this up now and so
I do think that you know especially now
where you have sort of one-party rule in
Washington and people are feeling pretty
powerless about what they can do this is
an effort where you know the Oakland
City Council you know it must feel
irrelevant in blue California right but
it's not you know you can you can start
modeling policies at the local level
that will push out across the country
yes
I have a question about the first myth
of the security state being of
unprecedented nature of the threat so
you talked about the fact that in terms
of magnitude terrorism is like not that
significant like conventional Wars
preceding it killed many more people but
I am wondering whether the nature of the
threat whether you would say that it has
changed in terms of the tactics of the
perpetrators because it does seem that
that has changed substantially with
terrorist organizations employing covert
measure and you know blending into
civilian populations things like that
and whether that requires a different
type of response yeah I guess I mean the
first thing I would say is changed since
when I mean you know we had bombs
blowing up the Attorney General's house
in 1917 there was more terrorism in the
u.s. in the 1970s than there was in the
decade after 9/11 in terms of people
killed in terms of radical organizations
you know sort of blowing people up
hijacking planes you might say that
certain capabilities now are so enhanced
that it justifies a much different kind
of response and so you know the the
ultimate bogeyman that we heard was you
know nuclear experts and you know that
wing of the security state and you can
go back and find these quotes from 2001
2002 2003 2004 and they all say we
predict that there's a 50% chance that
someone will blow up a dirty bomb in an
American city in the next six years of
course no one ever goes back to look at
those but they all every one makes the
prediction now my view is that nuclear
proliferation is a threat that's outside
the model that I've been talking about
today that's an existential threat and
it justifies nuclear proliferation we
should be much much more serious about
that internationally and making sure
that those kinds of materials are locked
down but in terms of terrorism you know
the real question is how should we treat
it you know does it make sense to spend
you know eighty billion dollars a year
on a military response to something that
even if it looks different it's probably
better handled as a gumshoe law
enforcement issue
and and one part of this that I didn't
get at is the way that our treatment of
the terrorists that indicates their view
of themselves so they see themselves as
warriors they see themselves as engaged
in a civilizational war against us we
shouldn't aggrandize them that way I
mean we should call them the criminals
and murderers that they are and we
should punish them I mean again it is an
amazing thing that there's been no 911
trial why is there not going to trial
you know because we decided to treat
this as this wildly exceptional thing
and because we tortured those people so
badly that now it's very complicated to
even bring them to justice but no I
guess my general view is that you know
for the most part terrorism looks a lot
like it always has and that you know we
don't compare it
we don't think enough about how much in
you know how rates of terrorism have
been fairly steady over time in free
societies yes
what can each of us be doing to really
get gold we think misinformation yeah I
mean I it's a hard question and and
nothing that I'm talking about is
something that you can do a whole lot
about on an individual level right
but I'd you know when when you hear
somebody say you know I don't care if
they know everything that's on my cell
phone because I didn't do anything wrong
and they're protecting me from terrorism
we tend to focus on the part of it of
you know whether you've done something
wrong we don't tend to think enough
about the predicate for the question you
know what is this scary threat that
justifies they're looking at private
information on your cell phone right I
mean so I I do think you know it
collectively yes
collectively we can we can promote the
idea of courage and resilience in the
face of a terrorist threat so one one
one one not nice thought but one that we
need to have now is how is President
Trump going to respond to the first
substantial terrorist attack in the
United States it's coming it won't be
9/11 necessarily but it might be on the
level of the bottle on attack in Paris
which killed a hundred people or San
Bernardino which killed sixteen or
Orlando 49 and how are we going to
respond to it you know I think they're
expecting us to respond like sheep and
to fall in line and say now we realize
you were right and you we need your
protection so that you can protect us
from this one in four million event so
how can we respond differently you know
in Paris there were millions of people
on the street after those attacks it
didn't stop their government from
passing bad laws but I think there was
this sense of solidarity like let's
let's have that let's not do what you
know it's hard after the fact to
criticize Boston but I think it was a
disaster that they lock down a major
American city for a day and a half
to chase a couple of people I don't
think that's the way that we should
respond I think that that makes again it
makes terrorists who they think they are
so you know who are you going to be
where are you going to be what are you
going to be doing the day after the
first terrorist attack here and the
Trump administration that's something to
think about
yes finally in the Intelligence Agency's
best interest to advertise countering
attacks and preventing them I think it
probably is in their net interest to do
so but there are certainly I can I can
imagine that it is is doing so first
that it could give it could come up with
give terrorists ideas this is something
that we stopped once but it's not
necessarily something that we could
always stop and be sure to do so it
could encourage terrorists by saying
you're right look here are 50 attacks or
here are here are 10 attacks is tonight
it's an example of how many other people
hate the United States
it could also scare the public which
would upset politicians and I I know
that I think there is a tenuous balance
between wanting to scare in public but
not wanting to freak them out too much
and I also like think that the
intelligence community they're
encouraged speech screen by nature of
what they do and lastly like one big
difference between using the technology
for speeding or for monitoring our cell
phones is that or I guess the better yet
we'll be putting frog Weiser in our car
is that something we would see a feel
whereas our telling folks we don't
really were not aware we know it but we
don't feel it on a daily basis and if
we're made aware of these things and
everything that the agencies are doing
that could create an opposition to it so
I think everything that you just said is
logical and rational I just think it's
wrong I mean no I do I just think it's
empirically wrong I and I wasn't arguing
about what's in the interests of
intelligence officials in terms of
disclosure but rather what's in their
nature there well I mean maybe those
aren't totally
two separate things but think about you
know you're you're a senior official in
a gargantuan bureaucracy that has
justified itself for a half a century
because of a cold war that is a genuine
existential threat and how do you when
that cold war ends you know sort of
justify the massive authorities and
budgets that are flowing toward and you
know it in the 1990s when people are
writing books called the end of history
and how are we going to send the peace
dividend you know this is when terrorism
emerged as all of a sudden not the way
that we had treated in the u.s. before
which is this radical nuisance something
that was a not an existential threat but
not something we could eradicate but
something on the level of the Cold War
and so yes look I think that they are
always looking for ways to advertise
their successes and to justify the
enormous Authority and the enormous
money that we give them again the the
actual truth involves you know there's
not one person directing this conspiracy
there's millions of people who hold
security clearances and many of them
most of them are indeed honorable public
servants who are you know doing
important work for the country I just
think that it's wildly out of proportion
to what the country needs right now and
that in a lot of instances you know
involving you know Wars of choice and
invasions and things like that it
creates far more problems than it solves
but look there's no question that there
have been times when our intelligence
agencies have had successes that they
have not broadcast until much later
because they didn't want to show the
sources and methods that they use in
order to get that intelligence no
question things like that happen all the
time so you know I don't want to say
categorically that that never happens
it's just that with with terrorism it
would be shocking to me if when you know
the papers from this error gets
Declassified in seventy five years we
find out that in fact you know Cheney
and Bush and Rumsfeld and these others
you know stopped massive terrorist
attacks
and didn't tell us about it yeah you
mentioned earlier the question is being
outside in this model here advocating I
think in reality they're actually
extremely entangled with these terrorism
questions in terms of how are how we
handle you know proliferation but maybe
more so bioterrorism risk and how that's
very deeply integrated into like what
DHS does yeah so how do you well let me
ask you why do you think there hasn't
been a bioterror attack I mean so there
was ility issue but well I mean so in
Tokyo when did oh I'm sure ku used sarin
gas in the subways when was that in the
early 90s yeah I mean again I I don't
think terrorism is that hard that kind
of terrorism I mean we probably will get
to a world where the capability of like
a kid in a basement lab to inflect huge
damage on lots of people is something
genuinely scary it doesn't follow that
giving eighty billion dollars to the
military you know to deal with that
problem is like the RET it's better than
having the police try to do it so but I
might have cut off part of your question
I would I would just say I mean sharing
the chemical taxes that's not yeah
painted existential threat right and I'm
the I'm the bio warfare question it is
that is a possibility the question is
yeah we move that money from the
military to science stuff that can
actually deal with that more effectively
and how you practice they are entangled
now weather sure you're wrong
how does that process I don't know that
there are people who are you know sort
of teaching classes in different kinds
of schools now about you know the the
future of you know terrible weapons
there are books written about this now
and I don't really have an answer to it
it you know if you if you spend too much
time thinking about it it will keep you
up at night right you know in 1980
everyone was worried about people having
the you know the recipe for making an
atomic bomb and there were lawsuits
about you know whether magazines could
actually you know publish the secrets
and it turned out you know
having the information wasn't enough
there were both problems of getting the
materials and the fact that there are
not that many people who really want to
blow up an atomic or nuclear bomb right
most of the terrorist organizations are
you know you need to think about them as
political not it doesn't help to say
there are crazy people who hate our
freedom it helps to situate them in the
political context in which they see
themselves it's not in the interest of
most of those groups to detonate a
nuclear or atomic weapon probably right
but still we're going to get to a time I
think the bigger problem is not going to
be you know a terrorist organization
it's going to be a you know a genius PhD
in a lab you know with a mental health
issue all right and again I'm not sure I
see that as a question of national
security and way that I'm talking about
it but it's certainly a problem
yeah I wonder your city you elaborate a
little bit more on what you see as new
potential politics emerging out might
emerge they have trouble seeing how that
might come about
you see it as the median American voter
actually changing their views and
conditioning their voting on these types
of issues you see this as a smaller but
committed group that takes part in
fashion I mean politics during what's
what will give you specific thing but
you see that thing well I mean you know
for one thing resilient is a term that
you actually hear in military circles
and then you know if you saw the
response in the UK to the recent terror
attack near the Parliament right that
there's a whole practice now that you
know sort of law enforcement have we
can't prevent these kinds of things but
how can we instantly move to minimize
the harm how can we have our first
responders closer how can we you know
shorten the gap of time between injury
and medical interventions and all those
kinds of things I do think that there is
there's a sense that you know this
conversation needs to happen you know I
think one of the silver linings of this
presidency is that it you know it will
what you know Trump is not going to get
the same response to saying terrorists
are scary that Obama got or even that
Bush got or Cheney God and you know
people so distrust him in their guts
that it's actually going to create some
of that space I think again you know
seeing those spontaneous protests to a
national security policy that was
discriminatory that was something really
remarkable but I don't have a I don't
have a political program you know I mean
I I'm at one side of this you know more
involved in the litigation side of it
it's more that I want to provoke this
conversation so that people are thinking
about it yes yes you talked about how
soft that is really courts have done a
better job of drawing of lines in
determining since all curious us whether
you see that other countries are doing a
better job reacting to this new mounts
or terrorism and why you think that
might be why did yeah and I guess to be
clear I wasn't even commenting on how
the Israeli High Court was deciding this
issues I was commenting on the fact that
they were deciding them right so that
here our national security discourse has
actually taken judges out of the process
all of the national security judicial
doctrines are about you know deference
we have a doctrine called you know
political question when we tried to
establish boundaries for when the US
could fire drones the government said it
was a political question and the court
agreed that's a political question
meaning it's a question for the
President and for Congress not for the
courts meanwhile you had the Israeli
Supreme Court grappling with that
question you know what are the four
conditions that have to be met before
the government can do a targeted
assassination right and again I'm not
here to agree with the outcome but but
just to say there are other legal
cultures including those that have there
very direct and probably more direct
experience of terrorism than ours
including Israel in many European
countries you know apart from 9/11 that
you know where their courts weigh in and
so you know all the torture victims that
I of all the torture victims that I
represented and you know many of them
had there's some tie to some other
country they got nothing from the US
they didn't get a day in court many of
them got compensated by European
governments for very minor roles in
these ordeals right so so those court
systems were actually willing to to kind
of hear these cases and even if they
weren't going to say you know this
leader is going to be held accountable
in this way they at least knew that the
victim needed to be compensated for what
had gone on so but I'm not a comparative
scholar so you know I can't say you know
these three countries do the best yes
yes sure yeah this talk had been this
month ago the first question would have
been never deny was Russian yeah yeah so
when Trump was elected all this stuff
about how his kid came later coordinated
with the Russians in healthy love came
out it all looked as though maybe
Snowden's ability state in the Soviet
Union not be repatriated here to be
tried in prison and of
you might have happened I think things
are kind of back released but at that
time were you afraid there might have
been a swap for something I've never
thought it was likely it's always
something I worried but I never thought
it was likely at just the time that
everyone everyone now apparently is a
Russia scholar in the u.s. if you if you
follow my social media accounts yeah
everyone seems to know everything about
what's going on in Russia of course he's
going to be sent back in that same week
you know the Russian government in an
administrative process extended his
legal residency there until April 2020
now that doesn't mean that he can't be
sent back at any time and you know what
makes me most uneasy is how often and
how loudly he criticizes the Russian
government over their censorship and
surveillance practices right now the two
places he can be are in Russia or in the
US prison but that hasn't quieted him I
mean he has criticized their
surveillance laws and called them their
big brother internet law he was speaking
out about their street protests against
the corruption a few weeks ago
I mean his view is he would rather not
be there but he won't be there at the
cost of silencing himself as he said to
me I didn't do this to make friends if
it means that I get sent back I get sent
back it would be uncommon I'm gonna get
everything about this case is uncommon
you know the trades that you hear about
are ordinarily when we catch their spies
and they catch ours hold on to them for
a while and swap them this is actually
something quite different than that
right and of course if you're Russia you
want 10 more Edward Snowden's when you
probably want them to be people who
don't criticize you and maybe actually
cooperate but still you want to
environment where people will walk in
you don't want them to think they'll be
traded back in the same way that we
would never send back to Russia or China
someone in the similar circumstance we
would never do it I think I could be
wrong it could happen tomorrow
one more yeah yeah just kept on
operating because I mean imagine if
we're back awesome fun has just happened
there's people on the loose we don't
know if you have more bomb that could
then be going off in the subway in
Street Keturah idea imagine then if we
yeah as usual keep on going and then a
day later these bombs are set off in the
metro you're right it's hard and I you
know I don't know what I would do if I
were the Boston police chief or the
governor Massachusetts or the mayor of
Boston I'm just saying that the result
was terrible the look was awful I mean
you basically told every nineteen year
old bozo here's how you shut down a
major American city and that's a very
bad look like that's terrorism
succeeding and so again III really said
that with some trepidation it's hard to
criticize the calls people make in the
moment I don't know what they knew about
who had done what but you know there's a
lot of situations where we have manhunts
in this you know in this country where
we don't shut down cities you know even
when we know that there are people on
the loose with powerful weapons
you know we tell people to keep a
lookout we do Amber Alerts we do you
know we do news reporting but we don't
tell everybody to barricade themselves
in their homes so yeah I mean it's a
it's a it's obviously a hard situation
because if you are a political leader
you get blamed for the death right and
so you end up taking these decisions
because they're the risk of Earth's
decisions to make but that I come back
to courage right do we want to live in a
city do we want to live in a country
where cities are locked down in that
situation every time Brussels was locked
down for a couple of days last year it
was terrible what a note to end on
yes yeah yeah
you mentioned that perhaps sort of a
gumshoe operation your local police
cities would be the more appropriate
place to deal with finding out who's
doing what almost always but a lot of
our local police have not such a great
relationship with minority communities
either and so it seems like there's
still some work to do in maybe local
politics more generally oversight of
police and and building a a more
community-based policing system I don't
know if you thought about that or yeah I
know a lot you know the NYPD which is
the famous has both so they have they
have more counterterrorism officers than
the FBI the New York Police Department
does right they have a thousand people
who are working on that alone and after
9/11 you know they were as bad as any
secret police force they were
infiltrating student groups they were in
mosques they were in restaurants they
were really selling distrust in the in
the community but they also are models
of community policing in other ways okay
yeah I mean I think no different
different but yes and within the same
within the same force and they've
actually now they're under consent
decrees that limit the ways in which
they can intrude into those communities
and bring them back to to a more
balanced approach but yes I mean your
point overall about policing almost
introduces a whole new difficult topic
to this conversation which is now that
we've agreed that it should be the
police and not the military how should
the police do it I could imagine them
getting very excited about these budgets
too and you could write in in the in the
80s the way that local police
departments got fancy equipment was by
being on Narcotics Task Forces and
working with the DEA
and since 9/11 the way that they get big
budgets is by being on Joint Terrorism
Task Forces and infusion centers and you
have these State Police people
doing trainings for state police in
upstate New York on the seven signs of
terrorism right I mean ridiculous things
and you know that I mean if you see some
of the brochures that these entities put
out it's it's you know it's unbelievable
you mean you would think that there were
terrorist attacks in the country every
day so that is a problem
yeah it's my fault for setting the town
yeah the difference between the group
seems to me can work works you better
break the break robber yeah a rebel
under clearly see I don't see why you
break those two well I guess the world
that I was contemplating is one in which
every single car in order for you to be
able to drive the car it has to be
fitted with that breathalyzer
now I actually wasn't raising it as a
legal issue I was raising it as a policy
issue would we favor that do we want to
live in a world where a car doesn't
start until sober breath is blown into
it I wasn't actually raising that as a
Fourth Amendment question at all I was
raising that as you know question of you
know is that an intrusion into our
personal liberty our lips why is it with
well I mean I think there are many
people in this room who have driven home
after a couple of beers maybe they
shouldn't probably they shouldn't I have
right a lot of us have in some kind of
circumstance and you know we I would I
would rather you know live in a world
where people work out and manage that
kind of risk
than one in which well I don't know I'm
not sure you could I mean you could set
it to that right again I think you
thought I was making a legal point and I
wasn't I was just giving examples of
already existing technology that could
save lives on the highway that many
people would oppose and I assure you
that there would be outrage particularly
in Western libertarian parts of this
country to a government mandate that you
can't start your car without glowing
sober breath into it there would be huge
now that might not be your issue at all
you may think that's a really easy one
great okay yeah and civil liberty isn't
a legal issue necessarily yeah okay yeah
I mean yeah I think we'll have to end it
up end it on that I mean what yes
exactly
yeah I mean there are you know people
who don't think it's the Civil Liberties
issue at all to go through a body
scanner at an airport I think it's it's
the most trivial thing in the world to
have a you know one of these scanning
devices shoot backscattered at you and
draw a picture of what might be in your
pockets it's just the farthest thing
from the issue at all but if you go back
to the 1960s
the ACLU was opposed to any kind of
x-rays and airports at all right I mean
that's not our position anymore but
people's views on these kinds of things
evolve so yeah we can do more okay I was
possible for citizens to observe it the
kind of courage you're discussing even
while distinct may not so for instance
you mentioned a box on it and said that
you know the people came out in
solidarity but simultaneously France
declared a state of emergency you know
suspended the Schengen privileges and
all of that for quite a while and so how
do you kind of where that yeah no I I
think the great point I mean I don't
have an answer to it I think but I
generally think that on these issues you
know my intuition is that there's a
hunger for leaders to behave in the way
that the public did in that case that
could be wrong the risk-free thing for
political leaders to do is to you know
say this is a essential threat and to
accumulate more power may be the riskier
thing would be to say you know we're
France and that's who we are and we're
not going to change a thing and I think
I really do think that if that if the
President had said that on that day you
know the people in the streets would
have been able to turn that into pride
turn that and you know rather than
rather than fear so maybe the people
have to lead could you just say one more
time you're the last line of your talk I
thought that was bad
we're going to do and there's global
independence of the course so if you
could just say that one more time
the last line was was with the you know
land of the free and home of the brave
but I do think that what well what I
meant was that that you know if you
think if you see these these legal
decisions that are constraining Trump
and your conclusion is the system is
working and we can relax right now
you're miss reading the moment that it's
the people who lead and the courts who
follow in these cases and that you know
if you were trying to litigate against
security policies in the years after
9/11 you know the atmosphere was one of
absolute complete deference to the
government at that time but I really do
think that you know in the first weekend
of the Trump refugee ban for judges
issued injunctions blocking it all for
who heard it that would not have
occurred if there hadn't been tens of
thousands of people not just in San
Francisco and at JFK but in Louisville
and in Dallas and spontaneously places
where you know foreign flights don't
even land people were going to airports
that became the place of resistance and
so if if you were in the streets for the
women's March or the tax march or went
to an airport stay in the streets it's
going to make a big difference yeah
[Music]
so that's rhetoric you talk to now and
how they're training themselves as
warriors I'm just wondering and that's
not something that's been happening
since the Churchill's but then before
the turtle was they were warriors that's
the next thing I think I think I think
what's going on is that you know these
these people you know the Lindsey
Graham's of the world you know want to
believe they need to believe that
they're part of a great struggle they
need to think that they're part of the
same kind of struggle that their fathers
and grandfathers were part of when there
were world wars going on and that's why
I say it's there it's an identity need
so you know the problem is that it's so
vastly out of proportion with the
reality of the threats that they're
talking about and it leads us into you
know really terrible places so you know
these senators insist on treating
terrorism detention as a military issue
and so you end up with a Guantanamo and
you end up with you know hundreds of
people being detained without charge or
trial because that's the way we do it in
war in war you don't have to do trials
you get to hold people till the end of
hostilities and so now we have hundreds
of people who you know might be innocent
or who could be prosecuted who are
instead sitting in these prisons it
means that you know you can target drone
strikes far away from anything that we
would consider a battlefield in our
traditional language of war and we're
just escalating the you know sort of
global violence and service of this
rhetoric so yes I mean I think there is
a lot of continuity
you know this the warrior language isn't
new
it's just so inappropriate for the
context right now in ways I think that
are dangerous of course perhaps people
who are getting commands or like shaping
the landscape yes definitely although I
would recommend a recent book by Rosa
Ehrenreich who served in the Defense
Department for many years about how we
actually over valorize the military in
this country to our detriment so you
know that we we worship the military in
ways that are harmful to democracy and
that harmful to the military as well but
yes the the point is not to say that we
shouldn't you know honor veterans who
actually served in war zones the point
is that we shouldn't define every part
of the you know our counterterrorism
efforts as part of a great military
struggle let's keep going yeah that also
actions that are taken are done for the
purpose of furthering our narrative and
improving a politician's approval
approval rating so I can see a lot of
reasons why like in the event of the
first character taxes from collections
the action anything it's a lot more
determined by using the supporters we
know I'm elated by etc so in terms of
messaging how do you think with that
that's a great point
yeah it's a great point how do you get
out of a feedback loop like that you
know that's that's why I was trying to
get at are we as afraid of terrorism as
our leaders think we are or did we find
ourselves trapped in this discourse you
know we're a fear of terrorism is some
kind of badge that we wear and how do we
turn that you know say fear shouldn't be
the badge courage should be the badge
right so
I don't know I mean that's why I'm
trying to provoke this conversation but
I don't have I don't have an answer to
that should we stop
[Applause]
[Music]